hey wassup guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to episode 24 of network chat
programming alrighty so today we're
gonna talk about basically handling
multiple clients and the awesome news is
that essentially after this episode you
guys are gonna basically have an entire
chapter I'm ready to go yeah it's pretty
much the end of the series I'm probably
gonna I'm probably gonna put in a few
more things that you guys wanted me to
but essentially after this episode we're
pretty much done right it's a functional
functional application there is one more
crucial thing we need to do after which
is handling the disconnection of clients
but um after today you guys are gonna be
able to send messages to each other you
can give this to your friend and it will
work and you guys can actually talk
remotely so I'm just just for a preview
of what we've got now if we go to our
seven main class I'm just gonna I'll
just leave it here I'll put it right
over here maybe if I launch that and
that launches a server of course you can
see that if we if we launched our login
oops I launched that twice okay yes I
did okay let's get her to one of them
okay and I go Y on localhost 8 1 9 to
hit login and and you can see that we
log in here but the important thing is
that we've connected to our server and
we can type stuff in but um that's
essentially where we're up to right now
right but what happens is the server's
you can see with this it receives all
this stuff but it it well it doesn't
really transmit it to other clients and
we're kinda well actually does transmit
it to other clients but our clients
don't receive it correctly okay so um
essentially what I'm saying to you guys
is if I launch another instance of this
and I'll call this one sure no local
host a one-line to login then we've now
got two instances in this probably gonna
be hard to see for you guys but um if I
say something on this instance you know
like hey it's not gonna show up on the
other instance and likewise if I say you
know what's up over here it's not gonna
show up over here okay and we're gonna
basically make it show up so did you
guys have a chat program to do to deal
with essentially so um the first thing
I'm going to do is I'm gonna go to
I guess the client right so the client
is what essentially all of the
behind-the-scenes networking for the
actual client window that's where it all
happens right and inside over here we've
got this method here called receive
right what this does is it receives any
inbound packet and it returns it as a
string okay that's what it does and then
that of course is used in the that of
course is used in client window where we
have this lists and methods are sorry
the client is the kind of network and
stuff and then climb wind it was the
interface so that's inclined right
there's a method called listening and as
you can see here it runs the client
don't receive method now if the message
starts with the C so in other words our
little seek and of prefix which
indicates that it is in fact a
connection packet so in other words the
connection should be established here
that's why we have this successfully
connected thing then then well with good
okay in a sense and it what we're good
in the sense that you know we can
connect if we get that kind of packet
however what we should handle is else if
the message starts with you know a
full-size and full slash because that's
our prefix for an actual message if we
go back to our server here and we look
at our I think we've got a thing here
called send to all or something sent to
all right it actually ought okay
actually just transmits it so in other
words if we go back to our client here
or our client window when we send
something and we've got a message here
you can see that our message receives a
prefix of this /m slash okay full / m4 /
so over here where we've got this full /
m4 / we know that it's a message that is
text that our all of our clients should
actually receive so what we can do over
here is say something along the lines of
well first of all what we want to do is
a guess we'll make a string message here
know what we want call a message that's
stupid we won't be able to actually
we'll call it text so message dot split
and then we'll use the rejects of em and
we'll use the pipe symbol of course to
indicate the or kind of in the rejects
so that we so that we actually well we /
both of them we split it by both of them
and then we'll pick one again guess it's
the same thing that we did over here
okay to separate it basically this will
just extract the text from amongst
everything else so now we've got the
text here and all we need to do now is
kind of send it to the console right so
we'll set we'll send it to the console
like this this is great I can it's gonna
work for a lot of it but um it's not
gonna work in one situation okay well it
is gonna work but it's just not gonna
look like we want it to in one situation
and that is since this sent to all
method that we have in server right this
sent to all method since that sends it
to every single client in this or is it
where's that cool and in this clients
ArrayList since the sensors to
everything it will send it to the the
source okay so in other words if me if
I'm talking to someone and I send a
message I want to get that message back
to myself all right now you guys could
do a very very simple little thing you
could do something along the lines of if
our current ID so if our client get ID
you know is equal to say the message dog
get ID so in other words when we get the
packet when we get the message we could
split it we could encrypt and close the
ID of a client and we could do it that
way if that is the case then you know
continue we could do something along the
lines of that but what I'm actually
gonna do is just make sure that instead
of posting our message straight away to
the console when we type it we're gonna
let this server take care of that rather
than the client so you guys know right
now if we type a message when we hit
enter which happens in over here I think
where's our Enter key okay if we hit the
enter it's gonna send this and over here
you can see that this send actually goes
console message right so what it does is
it prints our message to the console
let's not make the client do that
whatsoever let's delete that entire line
and so now we're not gonna get any
feedback from the client only from the
server okay so when we send something to
the server
it only gets printed in our history if
the server replies with it okay and the
reason that's really cool is it verifies
that there there is actually a
connection with
okay because obviously if we don't get
that packet back something's wrong and
that that I think is really awesome
and that's also good in the sense that
if you lose the connection to the server
you won't like accidentally send a
message thinking the other cousin got it
but they actually didn't okay so this is
like a really cheap easy way of handling
and ensuring that there is an actual
active connection that's working so um
that's pretty much it right this will
pretty much work right so if we launch
actually our servers still running so we
can go ahead and and launch our client a
login window here twice I'll launch two
instances of this right so we've got our
first one over here in a second one over
here call this one y on localhost
a-19 to this one we'll call sure no
localhost at 1 1 2 hit login it for both
of them you can see they're both
successfully connect here which is
wonderful and then what I want to do
here is just type in something like hey
ok and we get a response back to get two
responses and over here we get two
responses of care as weird what's up
okay so we're getting multiple responses
which is kind of weird okay now we're
getting three responses so we must be
adding another client somewhere else
yeah okay we are let's go back to our um
from the 101 that's happening let's go
back to server and I think if we go to
clients so we should be adding it all
right all right over here I'll have two
clients set out and we asked so maybe
we're adding it somewhere else is
probably the best bet and yeah we are
care that's pretty stupid so in the
receive thing before after we process
the packet which is what's supposed to
add it if it starts with C right over
here this line apparently we also do it
up here okay that must have been when I
was testing it so let's actually just
get rid of this client side and I'm
probably gonna get rid of this text as
well and that's this text right here is
just this text okay this one right here
right I'm probably just gonna get rid of
that because we don't need it kind of a
debugging thing and even if I run let's
just restart the server as well here if
I run the entire web if I run the entire
thing again so including the server man
and I will also run the I guess that
started let's run to
in instances here are two answers of two
instances of the client and will have
you know yarn over here local Jose one -
I am very not narcissistic as you guys
can see Jana and Jonah alright doesn't
matter um narcissus Jonah it's just a
test okay all right so hey and as you
can see what's up bro we get some
perfect kind of correlation here to pay
it appears on both clients dude what is
even up we should catch up soon anyway
I've spent hours personally talking
myself like this because it's very
entertaining and that's pretty much
gonna wrap up this episode okay and you
guys as you can see you've got a pretty
good connection here as in well in the
sense that you've got a um you've got
you've got an awesome connection here in
between the two client windows and it
all works and this will in fact work on
your entire network over the entire
internet ok if you do start the server
on a port such as a t1 line to please
remember to port forward that through
your outer if you plan to use it outside
of your internal network otherwise if
you're out of blocks that port which it
probably will you won't be able to
connect to the server and you'll
probably cry so um make sure you do that
I might do a bit of a tutorial on
setting this up to run on maybe even a
little server or something along those
lines as well as as just a home if you
want to launch it on your Windows
computer at home you know go to school
go to university go to work whatever and
and you want to kind of keep that server
yawn at your house and you want to you
want to get people to connect to it
while there's somewhere else then I'll
tase you have guys how to do that
perhaps if you guys want please leave a
comment right if you guys want me to do
that kind of stuff so that I can see if
it's worth my time essentially and also
Gil thing is the one thing that we
haven't covered this really important is
the disconnection of clients if I choose
to close one of these windows and it's
gone the server actually thinks that
it's still up so if I do something like
hey it's actually going to try and send
it to the other side and the pack is
gonna get lost and there's just no need
to do that and worse still if I connect
again we'll have problems ok it's
currently we have
to clients in this array list even
though I got rid of one of them so if we
go to client window whoops if we go into
the server this clients are right it
still has the size of two right there's
still two server client objects in that
array even though we've just gotten rid
of one of them so we need to deal with
closing it okay and the rate the way
that we can see if there's two of them
is if we put something along the lines
of I think I put this up here somewhere
where is it
yeah that's what we're gonna do in
manage clients actually but um we'll
talk about that in a minute we'll know
in a minute we'll talk about this next
episode but this manage clients is where
we're going to be doing the managing
okay now the reason we have to manage it
is because of two things one when the
user closes the program it's cool right
like as soon as they press that little
close button you know this little close
button this little close button here we
can do something right we can actually
listen for that and say that okay if the
user closes the button and now our
disconnecting or if they hit command key
or they go over here and hit quit we can
we can actually manage that right but if
they shut down their computer like
without closing this or they force a
shutdown or don'know the power plug off
their desktop pulls out and they've got
no battery and it just crashes or they
get a blue screen of whatever you know
for some reason all they're going to
come out into task manager and they
terminate the process for whatever
reason if it doesn't close cleanly
obviously the application is not going
to be able to send that disconnect
signal and thus we have to continually
check to see if the client is still
actually there physically right they
might be gone and that's what we call
the next step so different types of
disconnections but um as for this if we
go into I think there's a nice little
system out that prints the number of sir
okay here we go so in while the running
I'll just put a little a system to out
dot print line clients that size which
prints the amount the amount of clients
of course I bought - you can see it's
printing it here if I was to let me just
pull this up so that you guys gonna say
you can see it's printing - and you know
right now of course you just saw me
close the other one I've only got one
running if I start another one here and
again and I I don't know the chair no
this time a local hurt whoops
local host a-19 to log in then you can
see we've got three now okay
we've got this little three here and
that's uh I don't know if you guys can
see that we've got a little three here
now right and that's bad because that
means that is it's the server thing sort
of three clients but there or not so we
need to handle this connection and we'll
cover that next episode anyway I hope
you guys enjoyed this episode of network
chat programming if you did please hit
the like button below leave a comment
letting me know whether you want to see
that kind of service stuff after I cover
disconnection next episode and I'll see
you guys next time
oh one more thing I'm gonna quickly show
you guys this because if you are having
problems with the with the stuff which
you might be if you are having problems
with these episodes I have a lovely
website here called the Cherno comm if
you go to the forum section and you go
down into network chat programming you
can see that a few people have posted
here making you topic here you're gonna
have to log in here if you go to
register if you have it if you're not a
member yet we'll go ahead register if
you are go ahead it'll go ahead click
login if you're not and then once you go
to forums and to network chat
programming you'll be able to see this
wonderful little new topic button click
that type out your problem you know
include any code you'll have to log in
first obviously to post but you know go
ahead and post that forum and and
someone will help you okay me probably
but um maybe there's a there's the
wonderful thing about this is everyone
seems to be helping each other so I
don't even have to step in like game
programming is obviously the most
popular ones like tone resisting posts
now but now we're programming if you
guys need help you can see every topic
here gets answered which is awesome but
um that's gonna wrap up this episode if
you guys enjoyed it and I'll see you
guys next time goodbye